[Musique]
décembre 2020 le ciel commence à se
dégager pour boeing la compagnie
brésilienne gol est la première à faire
voler ses boeing 737 après les avoir
immobilisé au sol pendant 20 mois à la
suite des deux accidents mortels
d'indonésie et d'ethiopie qui ont fait
346 victimes
aucun problème du côté des pilotes même
chose pour l'équipage
les passagers pour la plupart ne se sont
aperçus de rien après le brésil la fda
américaine a donné son feu vert avant le
canada et l'union européenne
leur agence de sécurité aérienne ont
exigé des modifications à l'appareil
ainsi le logiciel mks est améliorée de
façon à empêcher une perte de contrôle
en cas de signal de décrochage il sera
basé sur les données de deux sondes
d'angle d'attaqué au lieu d'une
enfin le câblage vers le stabilisateur
horizontal arrière est modifié boeing va
pouvoir enfin vide et ses aires de
stationnement encombré de 737 max depuis
presque deux ans et reprendre petit à
petit la production avec des commandes
pour 3300 appareils
il y a eu des annulations mais des
nouvelles commandes aussi 75 pour
ryanair le pdg de boeing est ravi fin
décembre le premier 737 max d'american
airlines heureux d'école de miami vers
new york la guardia
la compagnie en a 24 elle sent le besoin
de rassurer les passagers comme la
plupart des compagnies américaines est
prête à modifier la réservation
si le passager est réticent à monter à
bord d'un 737 max sans les pilotes pas
de retour possible de la confiance
je n'hésiterai pas de faire monter à
bord ma famille ou la vôtre
tous les pilotes ont-ils cette confiance
certains ont des doutes
le capitaine chaises lits soli
sollberger
celui qui à poser son airbus en douceur
sur la route seul à new york en 2009 a
dit récemment que les modifications
n'étaient pas suffisantes il a l'appui
de dénis staged président du syndicat de
pilotes l'ied paris l'association qui
représente ce américaine
il répond au pdg de boeing david calhoun
qui affirme que le mac c'est le plus
haut de tous les avions actuels c'est
prématuré dit il à eux s'ajoutent des
familles des victimes et des ingénieurs
comme gilles primeau qui voit encore des
faiblesses dans le système de
stabilisateur horizontal arrière iard de
questions je rêve râle sur un 737 max
hild amar sur cet appareil des systèmes
totalement désuet cno n'accepte rai plus
aujourd'hui et que il coûterait pas
tellement cher à améliorer pour rendre
la région beaucoup plus sécuritaires au
même niveau que les avion comparable
d'aujourd'hui par exemple airbus 320
qu'on sait que le c3 7 mars c'est à
l'avion qui à la base à 50 ans qui est
une série dans fait de sparadrap ce
qu'on appelle en anglais des listings en
octobre
littéralement du rouge à lèvres sur un
cochon dit il mais le mac ce n'est pas
le seul problème de boeing c'est la
troisième crise qui fera vraiment boeing
d'affilée et en commencent eux on peut
le dire ouvertement
bon on commence quand même à s'inquiéter
un peu sur l'avenir de wayne dans l'état
pour couronner le tout il ya la pandémie
qui paralyse toute l'industrie
mais il ya aussi de graves problèmes de
qualité dans presque tous les produits
de boigne dans son appareil phare le 787
dreamliner avec de graves anomalies en
particulier dans l' usine de charleston
en caroline du sud
la sortie de son tout dernier le plus
gros le plus cher le triple 7x est
repoussé à 2023 et la certification
après les débuts
du mac ce sera plus difficile à obtenir
et puis il y a moins connus le fiasco du
ravitailleur militaire kc 46 une
carlingue du vieux 767 avec un cockpit
de dreamline défauts de construction
retable livraison il va coûter le double
de ce qui était prévu tout ça explique
les résultats financiers catastrophiques
de 2020 une perte de 12 milliards de
dollars et un moyen terme
aucun nouvel avion sur la planche à
dessin alors qu'airbus rafle les marchés
avec son a350 concurrents du triple 7x
et surtout son a321 neo dont le seul
concurrent est encore le fameux 737 max
sans oublier les à 220 les anciens
cseries de bombardier que boeing a tout
tenté pour faire disparaître
on reparle d'une troisième version
allongée après le sang le 300 ce serait
le 500 maintenant c'est certain qu'on ne
verra pas de nouvel avion par deux
boeing avant 2028 au plus tôt donc boe
est condamné à faire évoluer sa gamme de
produits actuelle donc le c3s jax de
7,87 éventuellement donc faire des
évolutions très timide
l'action en bourse a perdu la moitié de
sa valeur de 2019 avant les écrasements
alors boeing géant aux pieds d'argile
trop gros pour couler tout geek souffert
jeu on pouvait le dire on ne je commence
à avoir des doutes commencent à avoir
des doutes besoin de vision de renouveau
boeing est à la croisée des chemins
lormont
m